Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, this is going
to be my Jessica Jones trailer breakdown,
there's a bunch of new footage we finally
got some purple man and we see Trish Walker
she's been in some promo art, but we haven't
seen her in a trailer yet is also a lot of
rumors going around about the inhumans movie
maybe being canceled and phase 3 because of
all the extra stuff they been shuffling around
so I'll just clarify what's going on with
that up to the trailer stuff your goat Jessica
Jones the first part of the clinic just picks
up later in the night from the last trail
that I posted she just got done being that
shipped out of all those people in that bar
and now she's walking down the street she's
going back to her office at alias investigations
the add on the street sign over here for Trish
talk that's Trish Walker from the comics or
superhero name is hellcat but like a lot of
daredevil characters even though she sold
in the comics I think they're changing her
just little bit you might not be hellcat on
this TV show the problem with hellcat is that
like some of her back story gets tied up with
the X-Men in Hank McCoy and is cool as it
is there's no way they can do any kind X-Men
stuff right now which also kinda dovetails
nicely with this next little bit in the trailer
everyone's asking did she jump onto that fire
escape or did she fly and I think that she
just jumped my understanding is is that they're
not gonna let her fly during the series just
to keep her from being overpowered so big
like a slightly to them down version of Golden
age Superman lately being tall buildings is
that no heat vision then later in the night
we see her inside her office just putting
up pictures on her evidence board is kinda
hard to make out some these pictures but here's
another picture of Trish Walker so she might
be doing a case for Trish Walker purple man
might be going after because you can't hear
the David Tennant voiceover your words like
I know all your secrets I don't your friends
are Trish Walker is one of her friends so
he might be targeting people close to her
this is good also be from like some other
random case that she's working just like daredevil
season one was all about that one legal case
with Karen page I'm guessing Jessica Jones
is also gonna fall that model is essential
have like one really big case that she's investigating
that will get bigger and bigger and start
involving more and more characters would daredevil
first started investigating Karen page he
didn't know anything about kingpin or his
involvement Sangha I'm guessing it's going
to spiral off the same way with Jessica Jones
investigations the actual title that first
episode is called ladies night so it sounds
like she's going be in the shed out of a lot
of people in a bar which sounds like a lot
of fun so just gotten a taste of the purple
man I'm kinda wondering what they've done
with his powers to because very clearly his
skin is not can it be purple but he has a
certain level resilience Jessica Jones is
superstrong so we might see her beat the shed
out of him injured him just eat it and just
soak it up is not telepathic but he can give
people visions with his fair Melissa he exudes
pheromones and gives him a low level of control
over people is like a biochemical thing so
there's a lasting effect even when he's not
in proximity to you soon this scene here what
she's hallucinating him speaking those are
is his pheromones still in her bloodstream
moving into movie territory and everyone's
freaking out about in human stuff just because
it may have gotten kicked off the schedule
there's a lot of talk about politics behind
scenes at Marvel I don't know anything about
that is so far off like the movie itself was
so far off initially that it's status is pretty
fluid UI I think they wouldn't hesitate Smoot
around it something more pressing came along
like of a sequel came along they needed to
do the person who helped rewrite ant Man Adam
McKay expressed an interest in doing inhumans
in the ramping up on agent to shield so even
if things don't work out with the movie like
Adam McKay does it up writing or someone else
they don't automatically assume that they'll
be able to do the royal family on the TV show
I always feel like the royal families going
to be big enough that they'll hold them for
the movies so just officially on paper Marvel
has not canceled the inhumans yet is just
talk about what's going on behind the scenes
about you know them maybe not doing it may
be doing it no one has been hired to do anything
for yet they even just confirmed that they
haven't started writing the Captain Marvel
movie yet because they feel like she's super
overpowered so they're still trying to figure
out what are her weaknesses gonna be like
what are her vulnerabilities their dislike
too many character problems they have to work
through before they can actually write a story
so that's just what's going on with phase
3 but the cool thing in the two is that they
talked about Madam mask at New York comic
con on agent Carter agent Carter for those
that don't know is going to premiere next
January just like it did last year it's the
same deal same drill that can have way more
comic book characters though so if you feel
like agent Carter season one was, comic book
light in season two is going to be way more
fun but coming up next am working in another
flash arrow video was new footage so be sure
to subscribe to get that all-time post that
before Doctor Who starts tomorrow so that
it should be like an early video there is
lots of cool stuff happening in New York comic
con this weekend if there's anything like
really really cool that all totally uploaded
to my channel I just posted the game of thrones
panel you guys that you can click here to
watch that game of thrones panel is the whole
thing and you can click here for all my other
agents of shield Marvel videos thank you so
much watching everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!